So by now hopefully you've bought into this idea. That it
makes sense to start a product by thinking at a high
level and not delving into details too soon. Now you're going
to apply that idea to something you've actually built before. And
the way to do that, is first you'll identify a product.
This doesn't necessarily have to be a mobile app, or even
an app at all. It should just be some product that
you've worked on in the past. Once you decide on that,
you'll think about what the intended UX was. And
I'm using this word intended, even though there's definitely
a chance you may not have explicitly thought about
user experience. You probably had some implicit understanding of
what you wanted this app, or this product to
feel like using. Next you'll make a Prezi Wireframe,
to help you focus on the high level flow
of this product. And then you'll find opportunities for high
level improvements. This can be rearranging this steps, adding a step,
or moving a step. Or hopefully by forcing yourself to write
down the flow of the product at high level, kind of like
this. You'll spot any opportunities for big picture improvements, good luck.